plus les jours passent et plus la
pression est forte face à la menace des
nouveaux variants anglais sud africain
ou encore brésilien
le gouvernement français a pris de
nouvelles mesures à propos de ses
frontières
après avoir annoncé mi janvier
l'obligation d'un test pcr de moins de
72 heures pour les voyageurs hors union
européenne la france a opté pour un
nouveau tour de vis à partir de ce
dimanche cet impératif est désormais
valable pour les voyageurs européens
restrictions similaires pour entrer au
portugal en italie en espagne ou encore
en allemagne la belgique pour sa part a
décidé de fermer partiellement ses
frontières
les voyages non-essentiels depuis et en
provenance de son territoire sont
interdits à partir de mercredi et
jusqu'au 1er mars des mesures parfois
différente d'un pays à l'autre
alors que la commission européenne tente
une nouvelle fois est de remédier à ce
manque d'harmonisation afin de maintenir
nos frontières extérieures et
intérieures ouverte
nous avons besoin de mesures ciblées qui
nous protège tous et au vu de la
situation sanitaire aggravée nous
déconseillons les voyages non essentiels
à la fois dans le pays
et bien sûr au delà des frontières une
entente fragile alors que la troisième
vague de kovy 19 qui s'abat sur l'europe
pourrait s'amplifier au cours des
prochaines semaines de nouvelles mesures
prises en ordre dispersé par les états
membres mettraient alors une nouvelle
fois l'épreuve l'unité des 27